[Music]
after one fun movie
and a sequel that felt like sniffing
glue in the dumpster behind the arcade
too bad you will die
comes a reboot that will try to please
the biggest fans of the legendary
fighting game
splat seems that throughout history
different cultures all over the world
they
reference a great tournament look my
research shows that there's
realms in species that we didn't even
know existed
who are you people moral comment for the
story is like watching pornhub for the
comment section
mortal kombat dun dun dun dun dun dun
dun
do you want a martial arts flick that
takes itself way too seriously
or do you want a campy b movie full of
wings to the audience
get over here yes in a film with
dramatic scenes where liu kang can't
stop his cousin from getting sucked
off he's about to get his soul sucked
and goofy scenes where he spams back
plus low kick until his opponent rage
quits that's the only move you know mate
re-enter the world of mortal kombat and
when i say world of mortal combat
i mean the sandpit where everyone
pre-games before mortal kombat actually
starts
cause when it comes to the tournament it
will have to wait for the sequel
and even then screw it everything's made
up and the points don't matter
and read a cast full of legit martial
artists not that you'd ever know it
cause it's shot with so many quick cuts
it feels like your game is lagging
[Music]
led by the ancient rivalry that the
trailer sold you on
scorpion versus sub-zero
just kidding they have one fight at the
beginning and a quickie at the end
instead follow along with cole young
the harry potter of luke skywalkers i'm
an orphan
it's not a birthmark call you won't find
this character in your prima guide
but you will fight him getting his ass
kicked by everyone
he's a washed-up mma jobber who takes
fight advice from a little girl
but when cole lives up to the legacy of
being scorpion's trust fund kid
you're a descendant of one of the
greatest ninjas
to ever walk the earth he'll transform
from cole young punching bag
two cole young a guy with a tight shirt
and some
billy clubs uh no intel scorpion but i
think striker may have banged his wife
but cole's not alone test your might and
patience
against a massive roster of fighters
like liu kang
kung lao and raiden guardians of a
secret cult that helps branded people
fulfill their potential
sonja blade a woman hey no girls allowed
the training areas for the chosen ones
jax who goes from having nice arms to no
arms
to bad arms to good arms before you can
ask
wait what would his powers be if he
never lost his arms
oh a sorcerer who can't wait to leave
our world because
i mean come on look at it a bunch of
c-listers who are just there to donate
blood
the animation team for mortal kombat
annihilation and of course
kano
i don't know if this is a credit to the
actor or an insult to the script but man
kano is by far the best part of this
thing as you hate to love or australia's
main export
[Laughter]
so strap in for a feature-length teaser
for a future movie that may one day
contain
a mortal kombat tournament that does a
decent enough job of bringing the world
to the screen
but refuses to move anything forward or
develop any stakes at all
death is only another portal but who
cares
weirdest here to watch fatalities
without learning the button
movie combos adequate victory
starring dom seeking sub
frosty the ronin see my vest
see my vest the girl wants the dragon
tattoo
the croc hunter booyah welcome
to the scorch hey at least he's not a
white guy this time
the sun can place brim job you got a
little something on your
no a little bit lower no it's kind of
everywhere
it's literally all over your face for
loco
clever go and any excuse to play chris
from kung pao enter the fist
bye
it's not a birthmark cole means you've
been chosen open
your mouth
fighting requires both attacking and
defending not just throwing punches you
should try it sometime we have purposely
trained him wrong
as a joke get over here
unreal tournament
where are all my favorite mortal kombat
characters spawn
predator robocop schwarzenegger now
that's a sequel worth baiting for
[Applause]
what do you do with a didgeridoo
get over here six feet please
epic voice guy wins fatality
this voice is rated e for epic
honest trailers post comment scene
starts now